-Your life, your career
has obviously taken
so many unexpected
but also well-deserved turns
to the place where you are
obviously playing
a police officer on one of
my favorite shows,
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
a show with as diverse a cast
on network television
that you can find.
And, yet, you guys are
playing police officers.
Do you expect that
the events of the day
are going to affect
the next season?
-Definitely. You know,
we actually all got on
a Zoom call just the other day
because of what's happening
in this country.
And we were witnessing so many,
you know, just abuses of power.
We had some somber talks
and some really,
really eye-opening conversation
about how to handle
this new season.
-You tweeted something this week
that received some backlash.
Do you want to take a minute
to speak to it?
-Yeah. You know, one of
the big things that I tweeted
was the fact that
I felt that, you know,
defeating white supremacy
without the help of white people
could create a black supremacy.
Now, the term "black supremacy"
was just destroyed.
I mean, and what
I was trying to --
What I was trying to say is that
the fact that, you know,
I, as a member of
the black community,
there have been
so-called "gatekeepers"
who decide who's black
and who's not.
And in this effort to, you know,
to really push equality
and to end white supremacy
and systematic racism,
there are certain black people
who have determined that
what I'm doing has no bearing.
I have been rendered moot
because I am successful.
And my point is just the fact
that we need all of us.
When you are talking about
women's rights,
women's rights without men,
nothing changes.
If you don't -- If men don't
understand how to treat women,
we're going to have a problem.
And it's the same thing
with white people.
If white people don't understand
how to treat us
as a community,
we're going to have a problem.
But also, in our own community,
we have to know
how to treat each other.
And we have to allow ourselves
to agree, to disagree,
to have different viewpoints,
because right now,
in the words of Joe Biden,
if you don't vote for me,
you ain't black.
And these are terms that are
even passed around
within our own community.
And I'm going,
"Guys, it's bigger than that.
It's bigger than that.
We are bigger than that."
And that was the point I was
trying to make,
but people held on to
the "black supremacy" concept.
And, again, it's Twitter,
and taken out of context,
anybody can roll with anything.
So -- But I do want to
let everyone know
that that comment and that tweet
was said out of love,
in an effort for reconciliation.
And I want to be the solution.
I do not want to be the problem.
And I do understand
that we need all of us.
We need every American
out there to contribute
to this new watershed moment
that we have right now.
I mean, this is an opportunity.
This is an opportunity,
and we can all get better.
But I do not want to see us
get more and more extreme.
That is the biggest, biggest --
That's the biggest point
I'm trying to make.
-I am often frustrated
by your many talents --
a professional athlete, an
actor extraordinaire.
And we've talked about
the fact that
you are also a graphic artist.
You gave me a children's book
that you illustrated called
"Come Find Me,"
and it's one of
my kid's favorites.
And you taught an online
Zoom art class
during this lockdown.
-YouTube came to me
with this whole idea about
"Celebrity Substitute."
And I got with a teacher
from Compton.
Her name was Rachel Wong,
and she teaches art in Compton.
And I joined her class,
and it was the most exciting --
To see the faces of
the students,
I mean, the bright smile and,
"Oh, my God, he's here!"
You know,
I just wanted to be a light.
You know, I love art.
Art really saved my life
in so many ways,
and I can see what that can do
for other people.
And I can't wait to do it again.
I am actually, like,
trying to figure out
a way to sneak in
some other classes.
-Well, there you go.
If you're an educator --
I know most school is over --
but Terry Crews is available to
pop into your Zoom art class.
-That sounds good.
-Hey, thanks for speaking to us.
It's always such a pleasure
to see you, Terry.
Stay healthy and well
and give our love to Rebecca.
-Hey, love you, Seth.
Thank you so much, my man.
-Alright. I'll see you soon.